et pour en parler on retrouve nicolas
vidal éditorialistes nicolas vidal
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france on vient donc
d'assister à un sprint législatif est de
vous d'abord surpris par l'adoption de
ce projet de loi mais maintenant
heureusement doha non je ne suis pas
surpris ce que je suis surpris par
contre par la fanfaronnade de
dessinateurs finalement qui nous ont dit
qu'is avaient eu un compromis rappelez
vous il ya un après midi et une
suspension de séance de la commission
paritaire bien entendu mais finalement
qu'est ce qu'ils ont gagné les sénateurs
qu'est ce qu'on gagne et sénateurs
absolument rien et sénateurs hier je le
dis 1 se sont couchés notamment sur
l'exclusion du pass à lithaire en
terrasses notamment bars restaurants
mais aussi pour les mineurs donc très
sincèrement que dora aujourd'hui moi
j'ai une nouvelle fois le goût comme il
ya quelques jours d'une mascarade
démocratique dans ce pays est une
nouvelle fois quand j'entends les
dessinateurs notamment républicain c'est
réjouir de ce qu'ils ont obtenu
mais en fait ils n'ont rien obtenu
pourquoi une orientaux parce que
finalement la fibre liberticide et
toujours dans ce texte dans ce pas
salutaire et on l'a vu avec beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de manifestants à ces
derniers jours pour pour revendiquer
finalement l'exclusion du passé a dit
hier dans ce pays voilà et justement les
français qui restent divisés sur cette
extension du pass sanitaires à quoi
faut-il s'attendre dans les prochains
jours on l'a vu le week-end dernier
encore des dizaines de milliers de
personnes étaient dans la rue
ben oui effectivement alors nous on a
entendu que militaire derrière nous dit
qu'il est sain 60000 personnes très
sincèrement c'est une c'est une blague
une mascarade y avait énormément de
monde partout où j'ai eu vu des petites
villes de vie moyenne ou avec beaucoup
beaucoup de monde dans ce pays donc on
voit bien qu une forte résistance spa
sanitaires et une nouvelle fois soyons
très clairs ce matin ce n'est pas des
anti vaccin c'est les gens qui sont
épris de liberté publique des gens épris
de liberté publique et mais vous le
savez probablement il y avait pas mal
aussi de vacciner deux jambes vaccinale
et manifestations parce que là c'est
violent ça porte atteinte à nos libertés
individuelles nous
berthe et collectives la façon de faire
nation ensemble et concrètement et
j'ajoute une dernière chose sur le texte
voté l'assemblée
il y avait 2 122 députés la question que
je pose c'est où étaient les autres pour
un test un test pardon qui est vraiment
extrêmement profondément effrayant
liberticide et donc non je ne suis pas
surpris
donc maintenant j'imagine qu'il va
falloir attendre la saisine du conseil
constitutionnel dans quelques jours pour
voir on peut si ça va tenir la route
cette histoire justement sur canning
voilà le conseil constitutionnel va t'il
plutôt se mettre ce qu'il va valider ou
est-ce que là aussi ça risque de poser
quelques questions bayer une question
qui se pose moi je suis effrayée je vous
le dis ce matin doha sur l'histoire du
licenciement nos coûts nous a dit il
n'ya plus il n'ya plus de licenciements
dans le droit du travail mais on nous
parle ce matin lors j'ai lu deux fois le
texte 1 ce matin dès potron minet et je
lis dans le texte suspension du contrat
de travail et de la rémunération alors
moi je pose la question nouvelle fois
que j'ai beaucoup de questions vous
savez doha c'est quelle est la
différence quelle est la différence
entre un licenciement une suspension
contre travail de la rémunération
et puis si au bout de deux mois le
salarié ne souhaite toujours pas super
maxi n'est que se passe-t-il et là on
pratique privée et m'en parle également
des agents publics c'est absolument
effrayant donc est ce que le conseil
constitutionnel va se mesurer là tu vas
mesure et l'aspect étant d'accord là
dessus je l'espère très simplement parce
que lui-même pour les cdt je continue
les cdd peut être rompu vous imaginez
l'atteinte à la liberté du travail au
contrat de travail qui est en vigueur
depuis 1913 c'est absolument ébouriffant
et quand l'hiver en musique c'est une
belle victoire pour la démocratie une
belle victoire contre le virus
laissez moi rigoler mais je rigole jaune
vraiment très très jaune ce matin
dernière question c'est que pas
sanitaire voilà et des gens et en misant
notamment dans les parcs de loisirs dans
l'est
cinéma son extension ce sera début août
pour les terrasses de cafés les bars les
restaurants également les transports
quelles conséquences économiques
justement avec cette extension du passé
des terres c'est une très bonne question
parce que les jeunes les premiers
éléments
j'ai fait ma petite revue de presse ce
week-end et je me suis rendu compte dans
leurs articles de la presse locale et de
nos confrères la presse nationale qui
avait une baisse vertigineuse de la
fréquentation dans les salles de cinéma
près de 70%
imaginez-vous est également un autre un
autre secteur très très très touché ce
sont les salles de sport il ya des
résiliations en rafales dans ses salles
de sport et on va voir ce que ça va
donner
notamment je le disais un feuillage
aujourd'hui à des démocrates et non
démocratique et surtout les vaccinés on
verra si les gens acceptent finalement
ce cadre de vie cette proposition de
cette nation ce jour d'après on verra si
les gens vont accepter même vacciné
d'aller présenter les cuire comme
partout dans les cafés dans les
restaurants dans les centres commerciaux
donc ceci à mon avis va être pour porter
une lourde très lourde atteindre un
homme d'un modèle économique déjà bien
normal en ce moment avec la crise du coc
vite vous le savez que ça fait un an et
demi que nous sommes nous sommes dessus
et très sincèrement ça pouvait avoir des
conséquences absolument catastrophique
dramatique pour notre économie
voilà merci beaucoup en tout cas à
nicolas vidal d'avoir réagi ce matin sur
notre antenne je rappelle que vous êtes
et l'italie est